it's about 6 26 any wednesday morning
ready or not nascar racing into southern
nevada four days worth of fun at the las
vegas motor speedway so whether you're
going to the star nursery 150 tomorrow
night or the victoria's voice foundation
200 friday night or the ousco uniforms
302 on saturday afternoon or the big
southpointe 400 on sunday maybe you're
going to all of them
well the las vegas motor speedway wants
to keep traffic in and out of the area
as manageable as possible by the way the
nevada department of transportation says
there will not be any lane restrictions
through the ongoing construction there
where the 15 meters of the northern 215
beltway so that's good while a lot of
people do take the i-15 straight up to
the speedway there are some better
alternatives depending on where you're
coming from so from the far west the
northwest and northern parts of the
valley you'd be much better off just
jumping on the 215 all the way over to
the 15. from northeast clark county
obviously it makes sense to take the 15.
that's about the only way they can get
there
meanwhile for the southeast valley
henderson boulder city try i-1195-515
to las vegas boulevard skip the freeway
take las vegas boulevard all the way to
speedway entry number three buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy you
can email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com